Stephanie Mehta: Welcome, Anjali.
I'm so glad you're here with us today.
Anjali Sud: Thank you,
it is great to be here.
SM: At Vimeo, you lead a workforce
of 1,300 people worldwide --
you have creatives,
you have finance people,
you have technologists.
So I'm going to start
with a really easy question:
what was it like to manage
this diverse workforce
through a global pandemic,
a racial reckoning
and a very fraught return to office?
AS: Oh, it was a breeze, Stephanie.
No, it was really challenging.
You know, I think
the only constant has been change.
And as a leader,
you obviously -- you have a workforce
that’s looking for certainty,
and they're looking to control
what's happening around them.
And I think what we all found, as leaders,
no matter what company
you were ... responsible for,
was that you couldn't offer certainty,
and you couldn't always control
the environment and the things around you.
And so, you know, for me,
it was really about agility.
How do we stay flexible as a team?
How do we communicate in real time
and keep people informed
as we try and move through things?
And then, also just how do we lead
with more humanity?
You know, for Vimeo,
one of the things I’ve really learned
over the last few years is
we each experience
the world so differently.
We have employees who are remote.
We have an incredible team in Ukraine ...
employees who are on the front lines,
who are literally at war.
On the other hand, you have people
in different parts of the world
who are experiencing
mental-health challenges or burnout,
and so I think it was
really just -- the hardest part
was not being able
to give everyone certainty,
not being able to just apply
a one-size-fits-all rule for everyone.
But I ultimately think it forced us,
as a company, to build more trust,
because to be agile and flexible,
and to lead with humanity,
you have to trust each other.
And so, I’m sort of optimistic that
actually we’re emerging from this time
with a culture that is more
flexible and nimble,
and also, hopefully, has more trust.
SM: Can you give an example
of something that you put into place,
perhaps during the pandemic,
to enhance communications or build trust
or create a greater sense of community
or even to communicate
that there is no certainty,
that is a muscle that you think
you'll continue to use in the organization
far into the future?
AS: There's a couple
of things that we did.
One -- and we are a video platform,
so I obviously have to talk about video,
but I mean this sincerely --
one of the hardest parts,
when you're all sort of disparate,
is you lose context and you lose nuance
when you communicate.
And we did make a concerted effort
to move away from email and chat,
text-based communication,
as much as possible,
and actually try, particularly
for our leadership team,
when we were communicating,
to do it with your face,
and your hands and your body
and your emotions.
And we did that through live streaming
a lot of communications,
recording a lot of videos.
We sent asynchronous video messages.
So I send ... I record my screen
and just send a note out to people.
Every new hire does a video
to welcome and introduce themselves.
A lot of our meetings
we’ve actually replaced
with just quick video presentations.
And actually, what that really did
was allow the humanity
and the context to come through
and I think that helped us a lot
to, kind of, stay close.
So that was one, I think,
really important thing.
Another important thing is, I think,
just creating mechanisms
to make it easier to talk about
when things aren't working,
because a critical part of being agile
is recognizing we have
an area that isn’t working.
And so one of the things
that we do at Vimeo is we try --
I do this in all of my town halls,
we do it in a lot of meetings --
is always talk about what's working,
what are our top three things,
and what isn't working -- yet.
And we've kind of created, I think,
a framework that sort of
takes the stigma away
from talking about what's not working.
And when you make that normalized
and comfortable for people,
I feel like it's allowed us
to be more open, as an organization,
about what do we need to change,
what do we need to pivot.
And both of those, being more video-first
in our communication
and being more transparent
and normalizing what's not working,
I think has been really helpful,
and certainly something
we’re carrying forward.
SM: I love that advice
about being video-first.
So many of our members of our workforce
live in a video world.
They're used to video
as a means of communication.
Which brings me to my next question.
You've talked about
how the organization has changed.
How do you see the workforce changing?
What is different
with the young millennials,
and even, now, the first wave of Gen Z
coming into the workplace?
AS: I think it's incredibly different.
And, you know, one of the things
that we think about at Vimeo a lot is
a lot of the mechanisms
and communication modes
that we still use today,
they're really antiquated.
They were designed
for a totally different environment
and a totally different generation.
But I see a lot of differences.
One of them, I think, is the line
between your personal life and work life
is definitely blending. ...
If you think about
your personal life -- look at TikTok.
This generation is used to consuming
content, learning, engaging,
in a very specific way.
And if they then have to come to work
and to be trained on a job,
read a 300-page manual?
Like, it's not going to happen, right?
Or if you miss the meeting,
and you have to watch the Zoom recording
of a three-hour meeting --
that’s just not going to happen.
And so I think that there is
definitely sort of this --
you know, we talk about
the “consumerization of enterprise.”
Those are just fancy words
for saying the way ... we communicate
and interact in our personal lives
is going to translate to work.
And so I definitely think
that's an area of opportunity.
The other thing I see
from sort of the generation,
the newest generation
coming into the workforce,
is sort of, of course mission-driven,
but I think there's a desire
to really understand
the “why” behind things.
And one of our communication mantras
is we never talk about the “what”
without the “why.”
And I think there’s a desire to --
the idea that, well, there’s a hierarchy,
or “My boss told me
that this is what we’re going to do” or --
that, I think,
is increasingly moving away,
and people, they don’t
just want to do something
because someone with formal authority
told them to do it.
They want to do it
because they understand why it matters,
why it ties to the mission.
And I think that that forces leaders
to really bring more of the “why”
into how we communicate
and motivate people.
So those are two of the things I see,
and then, you know,
the third I think is just flexibility.
I think -- and this is true of all of us,
but particularly the younger generation --
I think they’re looking for flexibility
and they want options and choices.
And it's not always easy and feasible
to provide ultimate flexibility,
but this is where I try
and orient it more to agility.
How can we have
approaches and principles
and be committed to things,
but also know when to question,
and when to actually pivot?
SM: Yeah.
Anjali, can you share a few examples
of ways that you at Vimeo have tried
to really be proactive
when it comes to addressing
or understanding
what your next generation
of employees are going to want,
either in terms of purpose
or in terms of benefits
or in terms of flexibility?
Are there programs or processes
you've put in place
that really speak to this big sea change
we're seeing in terms of values
from the workforce?
AS: Firstly, of course,
it's all about listening, right?
And I think, like many organizations,
the way we've tried to listen
and understand our workforce
is very similar: it’s Q and As
and engagement surveys,
and things like that.
And some of the things that we've done,
we have a people and culture NPS,
net promoter score,
the same way we have for our users,
for our internal teams.
But I would say one of the things
that we've really tried to do
is appreciate that when we get inputs
from our employees, 1,300 employees ...
you can’t look at the averages.
You can’t look at it all in totality
and try and pull out an obvious
"Oh, this is how everybody's feeling."
Because what you actually --
when you really dig into it
and truly listen and
do focus groups and talk to people --
what you’ll find is actually
there's very different experiences
and desires among your employees.
And so, I think for us,
what we've really just tried to do
is have a bunch of different
listening mechanisms
and then resist the urge
to conveniently pull, like,
"Oh, this is what everyone's feeling,
let's just do this thing as the action."
And it's hard, and we're still
kind of figuring it out,
but I will tell you, some of the things
that we've heard from employees
have changed our approach
to hybrid work or travel
or even things like
our approach to compensation
or our approach to DE and I.
So I think it's more just like I said,
that agile listening, constantly
really understanding what’s happening,
but not treating everything as, like,
an average or the same.
And for us, it’s been particularly stark
because we have offices and teams
in so many different countries
and the differences, they’re substantial.
They're really substantial,
about the way we solve different things.
And we used to have a very, sort of,
"One Vimeo" global approach
in the name of consistency and fairness,
and what we found
is we have to be more localized.
We really do. We have to
design mechanisms to support our teams
in a very different way,
because their experiences
and the world around them
is quite different.
So I think that's definitely been one,
and I will tell you,
it has involved a lot of --
as an executive team
and leadership team --
it's involved a lot of trying things,
it not working,
and changing them.
And a great example is our Q and A.
I feel like every leader I know
has a perspective
on whether they do open Q and A
or anonymous Q and A,
or real-time Q and A.
We've changed our approach
there multiple times,
and I know we will again,
because we're still figuring out
the right way to listen
and have a dialogue
with a very diverse workforce.
SM: I want to stay on newcomers
to the workplace for just another moment,
because another thing I hear from CEOs
of my generation and older
is a concern about making sure
that we are not just providing
our youngest employees
with the flexibility
and the purpose that they need,
but also the training and the wisdom
that comes, oftentimes,
from being in close proximity to a mentor
or to somebody who's done the job
for many more years.
What is your philosophy and take
on making sure that knowledge
transfer is happening?
AS: I think it's a major challenge
that I don’t know that everyone
will sort of have a solution for.
I think about that all the time.
We have a very distributed
workforce at Vimeo.
We have people in over eight countries.
My executive team is entirely distributed.
So I've really realized the benefits
of being able to have
a distributed workforce
and being able to attract talent
and just be more inclusive.
On the flip side,
there's definitely, I think,
a lack of the same kinds
of learning opportunities and mentorship,
particularly for the youngest folks
that are entering the workforce.
So I think it's a challenge.
One of the approaches
that we've been taking,
and what's sort of nice,
is we're modeling it at the top.
So if my entire executive
team is distributed,
that means I have to learn
how to provide real-time feedback,
mentorship and development
for a whole set of new executives
who have just joined.
We have sort of changed up
the executive team
almost entirely in the last twelve months.
So I’ve had to deal
with the same challenges.
And we’ve had to literally --
we call it our operating system --
we’ve had to design an operating system,
as an executive team,
for how we’re going to work together
in that environment.
How do we share real-time feedback?
How do we create the right
communication loops?
And so I think, from my perspective,
it’s more we have to be able
to do it ourselves and model it
and then, I think
it's a more proven mechanism
for young people.
I will say, like many companies ...
I do believe that in-person collaboration
is really important for learning.
We do have --
we bring people into an office.
If you're remote, we ask folks to come in
and spend time in a room with their team,
do social activities, all of those things.
I don't think they will go away,
nor do I think they should.
But, you know, candidly,
it’s an area that I don’t think
we’ve really figured out perfectly
and I think it's really critical
that as leaders, we do that,
so that this next generation
is able to get
the same growth opportunities
that we all had.
SM: Well, and it's interesting --
the tools that you mentioned
at the very beginning
of our conversation, around video,
can be really helpful there.
I've heard of a number of organizations
that have really encouraged
their young people to present,
as a way of having to go out
and find the information they need.
And then, because we have video tools
available to us now,
you know, they have an opportunity
to share their ideas
with a large group of people,
but first, kind of going through
the fact-finding and the research,
and then sharing their ideas.
In an earlier comment, you talked
a little bit about mental illness
and the different things
that people are bringing to work,
whether it is, you know,
exhaustion, burnout.
During the Black Lives Matter protests,
we had a lot of people
coming to the office
feeling trauma,
and feeling really personal issues
bubble to the surface.
I'm wondering if you can share
a little bit about how you deal
with this increasing personal --
you know, when people bring
their whole selves to the office,
which we encourage,
sometimes, they bring things,
parts of themselves that are challenging.
AS: Yeah ... I’ve always thought
the responsibility of a leader
is to empower people
to do their best work
and the responsibility of a company
is to empower our people
to do their best work.
And so, of course,
we have a real role to play
in supporting things
like mental-health issues or burnout.
And, you know, the way I think,
like many companies,
the way we initially
probably sought to do that
was more, you know, you're seeing
a problem and you're reacting
by trying to provide
mental-health resources
or support or time off.
And, I think -- and empathy,
just empathy.
I think that's really important.
And I always say,
to so many of our managers ...
just care.
If we just care,
a lot of things get easier.
You don’t have to design
a hundred mechanisms
if you just have the right people
in place who care.
At the same time,
I will say
what we’re realizing now,
in sort of this next phase,
is that that’s a reactive approach
and actually the root cause --
that we can control at Vimeo --
the root cause of a lot
of stress and burnout
is sometimes people
either don’t have enough ... focus,
we’re asking people to do too many things
or they don't feel like they're supported
in doing those things.
And that, I think, is actually
where we should be spending more time --
is how do we actually set
the right prioritization and focus.
There's some issue there, right?
There's a root cause there
that's a "Oh, I feel like I'm stressed
because there's too much going on.
I don't feel equipped to solve it."
Then, we should get
into the "What is the detail there,
and do we need to do things differently?"
And, you know, one of our themes
at Vimeo this year
was "Do less, better."
SM: As the economy starts
to, maybe, move sideways,
do you think that there are going to be
stakeholders who say, you know,
"Out with all of this touchy-feely,
the workplace-as-a-family stuff.
Where are my results?"
AS: Absolutely. I think the pendulum
has already swung pretty clearly.
I mean, I work in SAS,
software as a service,
so we already went
from "growth at all cost"
to "profitability," you know,
pendulum swing.
My perspective on this --
and it hasn't changed --
I think the best leaders and cultures
deliver results and treat people well.
And I actually think,
if you treat people well,
with kindness and empathy,
you will get better results.
And so, you know, for me,
I think what I observed
over the last few years is --
that part, I think, hasn't changed
and shouldn't change.
There were, I think, a lot of times
when companies, we did things because
maybe it was lip service
or we felt pressured.
And that's not going to be sustainable.
But that’s not what -- ultimately,
that’s not what people need, in any case.
So, you know, I sort of see it as --
the way you channel how you are caring
towards your employees
and how you are empathetic,
always should be in service
of helping people do their best work,
which will deliver results,
which will be good for the bottom line.
And you have to believe that.
You have to be committed to that
and if you use that consistently
in your decision-making,
it should not be a trade-off.
These are not mutually exclusive things.
SM: Anjali, how have you been
taking care of yourself
during this period
of tremendous turmoil and change,
but also growth?
You mentioned you just had a baby.
There's a lot on your shoulders.
How, as a leader,
do you practice some self-care
or how do you make sure
that you're getting the balance you need
to be the most effective
leader you can be?
AS: I think --
recently, the phrase I use a lot to myself
is “two things can be true,
both can be true.”
I say this a lot. And for me,
I think of it as, like,
"This job is hard,
and it's gotten harder."
We went public
at the height of the pandemic
and last year, market volatility
has been tremendous.
You know, we're obviously going
through a ton with post-pandemic,
we have a team in Ukraine
going through a war --
all these things that have happened.
And so, it's a hard job,
and it's an incredibly privileged job.
It's a gift, right?
And so, I think for me,
it’s sort of acknowledging
both of those things has helped me a lot.
The way I’ve tried to kind of lead,
has been -- it’s always been this way,
which is, for me,
it's I have to have passion.
I have to have passion.
I have to believe so deeply
that what Vimeo is doing is important
and matters for the world.
And if I have passion, I have energy
and then I will -- I can kind of
move through anything.
I have to find joy in my team.
I feel like, especially in hard times,
I look back at my career
and actually, some of my most
fulfilling times in work
were when -- in the
hardest business situations.
But it’s because it brought
a group of people together
all on one team,
and so I think that's been, you know,
a really big part of it.
And then, yeah, like, you have to be
a little selfish sometimes,
and take care of yourself.
And I am really fortunate.
I think I have a great
support network around me
and I do ...
My husband and I have a deal,
where on Sundays,
I disappear for a couple of hours.
I just disappear
and I walk around the city
and I listen to my music
and do whatever I need to do,
and that's really important.
SM: So you talked about how hybrid work
is going to look
very different in the future
than how we describe it today.
It's basically in office a couple of days,
work from home a couple of other days.
Tell us a little bit more
about what you could potentially
see that evolving into.
AS: I think the idea of an office
as a time and place
completely goes away.
And I think it’s really going to be
people are going to want to work
from anywhere, anywhere in the world.
Even the concept of
where you’re located is going to change.
And then the idea of like
“I’m going to work on this time zone”
or “I’m going to attend this meeting
that’s scheduled on this date” --
I think that’s going to go away.
And I think what you're going to find
is more and more work,
particularly from knowledge workers,
is going to be done anywhere, anytime.
Communication and collaboration
will happen asynchronously
and we will be using tools
and technology --
whether it's video, whether it's AI --
to basically enable that at scale
among many people, anywhere in the world.
And then I think leadership,
leaders are going to look different.
Because I think it's going to require --
if you think about the skill set
to be a global CEO 30 years ago
versus what that will require now --
I think in the future ...
the skill set is going to be like,
"How do you communicate
with diverse, global audiences
and employees across time zones
in a way that is effective,
that provides context
and alignment at scale?
How do you organize programs,
whether it’s compensation,
whether it’s, you know, training?”
All of that is going
to look very different.
But I think the ultimate thing
you’ll see is just ...
there were these constraints
that we’ve lived with,
whether it was time or place
or budget, in some cases.
And I think those constraints
are going to go away.
And the promise is that
if we are flexible and smart
and we use technology in the right way,
that we'll actually come away
a much more evolved
and efficient workforce.
SM: Well, I think you just showed us
some of the passion
that you've talked about
as being the thing that gives you energy
to lead that organization
of 1,300 people worldwide.
Anjali, thank you so much
for being here today.
AS: Thank you.
This was great.